[Musique]
au Nouveau-Brunswick la grogne contre le
plan du gouvernement de blend x d'abolir
l'immersion française dans les écoles
anglophones continuent de mobiliser par
un et enseignant le ministère de
l'Éducation mène une tournée de
consultation publique sur le programme
qui va remplacer l'immersion j'en
discute avec ma collègue Michel Bridault
qu'on retrouve à Mountain Michel c'est
clair l'idée d'abolir le programme
d'immersion française est très très mal
accueilli chez vous oui on sentait déjà
un mécontentement l'automne dernier
quand le gouvernement annoncé qu'on
allait abolir l'immersion française mais
là depuis les consultations publiques
ces dernières semaines c'est très clair
pourquoi il y avait 300 personnes à
Moncton surtout les anglophones donc des
familles qui tiennent à l'immersion
française il y a personne qui a appuyé
les plans du gouvernement il y avait
aussi 300 personnes à Saint-Jean une
région très anglophone du
nouveau-brongique personne n'a pu le
plan et à Frédéric Town la même chose
300 personnes et ça on parle de et
personne encore une fois n'a appuyé le
plan du gouvernement d'abolir
l'immersion et là on parle de famille
des des enseignants des enseignants à la
retraite donc tout il y a personne qui
est allé au micro pour appuyer les
plantes du gouvernement il y a beaucoup
d'inquiétudes par rapport à cette
décision la province pourquoi mais on
dit que ça va trop vite parce que c'est
déjà des mois de septembre que de
commencer à abolir l'immersion d'une
part et d'autre part les parents disent
que c'est ce qui produit les meilleurs
enfants bilingues l'immersion française
et les études le démontrent et en plus
on trouve que le gouvernement n'a pas de
preuve avec le nouveau programme pour
démontrer que ce sera meilleur pourquoi
dans ce cas là Monsieur Higgs semble
tenir tant que ça abolir l'immersion
il faut comprendre que le programme
d'immersion française c'est pour une
partie des élèves anglophones seulement
c'est pas tous les élèves qui suivent
l'immersion française environ un tiers
des élèves alors blinding tous les
autres élèves deviennent pas bilingues
lorsqu'ils sont en lorsqu'ils terminent
l'école du secondaire donc nous on va
annuler les mères sont françaises on va
avoir un programme pour tous pour que
tous les élèves arrivent au secondaire
et soient capables de converser avoir
une discussion en français lorsqu'il
termine l'école alors lui il a dit dès
septembre on va donc enlever l'immersion
française à l'élémentaire et les élèves
auront la moitié de la journée en
français la moitié de la journée en
anglais mais les experts les parents les
enseignants disent que c'est vraiment
faire fausse route bon est-ce que et ça
s'est vu dans le passé mais Monsieur X
n'a pas l'habitude de faire ça très
souvent pour être il revenir sur sa
décision
c'est vraiment un plan de blending
d'abolir les murs sont françaises on
sent vraiment que c'est lui qui en veut
plus qui veut changer le programme mais
là déjà il commence à y avoir une
certaine ouverture le ministre
l'éducation bureau gun qui assistent à
toutes les consultations publiques il a
laissé entendre la semaine dernière donc
peut-être qu'on va faire des changements
à la lumière de toute cette grogne qu'on
entend dans les lors de ces réunions
donc de ces consultations publiques
peut-être que il y aura des changements
il refuse de nous dire si c'est qu'on va
retarder d'une année l'implantation des
changements ou des nouveaux programmes
ou s'il y aura vraiment des changements
où qu'on abandonne qu'on va tout
simplement abandonner le plan d'abolir
l'immersion
est à mi-mandat à l'heure actuelle et il
compte énormément sur le vote des
communautaires anglophones à quel point
est-ce que cette décision là ou ce
projet est là pour avoir un impact sur
ses chances de réélection les
observateurs politiques commencent déjà
à dire ça mal c'est quand même un boulet
pour le Premier ministre Kings en ce
moment cette abolition de l'immersion
française ça ne passe pas du tout du
tout et c'est vraiment sa base
électorale les communautés anglophones
du Sud Moncton saint-jean-frédéricton et
ailleurs aussi dans le sud de la
province donc là il a déjà la communauté
francophone civile une bonne partie de
la communauté du moins ado pour des
décisions impopulaires concernant les
dossiers linguistiques et là maintenant
il commence à avoir aussi de la grogne
du côté de sa base électorale
anglophone et ça c'est pas très bon pour
lui il a 68 ans bientôt 69 on est à
mi-mandat les élections sont en 2024
est-ce qu'il va vouloir rester est-ce
que il devra faire marche arrière pour
s'assurer de garder du moins le vote
anglophone de la province si lui par
faut qu'il pense à l'avenir de son parti
progressiste conservateur alors
évidemment il y a beaucoup de questions
en ce moment sur l'avenir du parti sur
ce que l'immersion française pourrait
avoir comme impact sur
pour l'avenir du gouvernement de blings
réflexion au sein du gouvernement
présentement Michel Bridor mannequin
toujours un plaisir merci d'avoir été là
merci